since we now have a
quorum we'll go ahead and get started
here
shortly
all right I'd like to call the
subcommittee meeting together um to
order we uh of the six members we have
four
present uh and I'd ask is would one of
you guys want to take notes there a
volunteer or whether I can appoint to do
that you got that Meg thank thank you so
much okay representative Murray will
will uh take
notes so to start the meeting I just
wanted to sort of review our Charter as
a
subcommittee um last session a
substantial amount of discussion and uh
review of of several different bills
associated with the rules around citing
waste
facilities and one of the determinations
out of the environmental agriculture
committee was that we would form a
subcommittee to monitor the progress of
that rule making uh activity and so this
is the first
meeting that uh We've held on this and I
just uh the first question I've got
really for the committee is I believe we
should have followup meetings
periodically is that does that make
sense to everyone I think so and what uh
how often do you think would would make
sense just as a start point we can
adjust as we go but
just monthly
bonly you know I really I if it's if
it's okay I'd like to sort of get a
sense of the overall scope of what we're
looking at here today when we talk with
members from Dees and maybe can we come
to that conclusion would you be open to
coming to that conclusion yeah as we go
yeah that's fine I just just trying to
set the parameters up front of what
we're what we're talking about so uh I
think to start off with if we could have
and I'm sorry ma'am it
it's Sarah would you um start off and
and Leah Sarah and Leah um if you guys
could start off with
a a review of what you've been working
on I know you've been working on it
since the spring absolutely and uh uh it
would be helpful if you could give us a
a rundown we'd be happy to I'm Sarah uas
Kern or you can call me Sarah Kern and
I'm the assistant director of the waste
management division at Dees this is Leah
McKenna Leah is the administrator of the
solid waste management
Bureau director whims asked me to extend
his apologies that he was not able to
make it today but Leah and I are glad to
be here to talk with
you I thought it was help to begin with
providing a brief recap of the path that
we took to get where we are right now
having just last week sent out a draft
of proposed amendments to EnV sw800 for
informal public
input uh recognizing the the complexity
of the enw 800 rules which pertain to
landfill permitting and landfill
sighting and recognizing the interest in
them ahead of the formal rulem process
we held uh an informal listening session
last March to hear input from the public
about potential amendments to the
section of the solid waste roles uh
because there were several bills in the
legislature pertaining to landfill
sighting at that time we did not include
landfill sighting in that March public
input session uh but then after after we
saw um that the bills did not pass we
held a listening session in July to
focus on the sighting section of the
landfill
rules we reviewed the comments that we
received uh in those March and July
sessions and we incorporated what as
much as we could uh into a proposal to
amend the landfill permitting rules envs
um still recognizing a lot of concern
about this set of rules what we did was
we released last week the draft proposal
of the rules for public comment informal
public comment before we begin the
formal rul making process which is laid
out in the administrative procedures act
so those rules were sent out uh last
week and the public input
um uh phase ends on November 7th at that
time we will uh review all the ments we
received make changes to the rules as
appropriate and file our initial
Proposal with
OS then we
anticipate uh having a public hearing on
the rules as part of the formal Ru
making process in the early
Springtime and filing the final Proposal
with OSS in May that would be in advance
of the expiration date for the rules at
the end of June of
2024 I know this group received the
draft proposal but we thought it would
be helpful for Leah to provide the
highlights of that proposal so
Leah good morning again for the record
Leah McKenna and I am the administrator
of the Sol Waste Management Bureau at
Dees so we thought for purposes of
discussion we might want to um bring
your attention to about a dozen kind of
run through um Soup To Nuts in 800 some
of the highlight of uh of some of the
proposed changes that we wanted to make
and then of course entertain any
questions you might have and we'll we'll
do our very best to answer or if not be
able to get to An Answer um in short
order okay so within 800 uh what you're
going to see are sections that deal with
sighting requirements for landfills
design requirements operating
requirements and closure requirements
all surrounding
landfills let's start with 804 which are
sighting requirements So within the
sighting requirements we have uh
protection standards for groundwater and
surface water there are setback
requirements and there are other General
sighting
limitations so in
842b we are proposing adding storm water
and decomposition gas infrastructure to
the requirements that landfills and
infrastructure be located only in areas
where groundwater monitoring remediation
can be conducted prior to a release
having an impact on Water
Supplies further we have added that this
monitoring and Remediation can be
conducted prior to having an impact on
groundwater quality at the property
line This increases groundwater
protections by ensuring all
infrastructure is included in sighting
considerations and requires that
groundwater quality not be impacted as
it migrates off site which increases the
protection of water resources on AB
buding proper properties uh overall this
provision will ensure that there is
sufficient time to get in front of a
potential contamination issue before it
negatively impacts groundwater quality
at a property line or has a negative
impact on a water
body moving on to the section for
surface water protection standards we
wanted to bring to your attention 80403
C so this contains a new requirement
that a landfill be located in such a
manner that failures of the waste contam
the waste containment system or
infrastructure can be detected assessed
and a remediation initiated prior to
contamination reaching any perennial
water body so same as before the intent
of this is to ensure that there is
sufficient time to get in in front of a
potential contamination issue for it
negatively impacts a water
body 8040
3D that 200 foot setback we currently
have Dees is looking to revise that
setback to 500 feet um sure questions
will come so we'll try to I'm going to
try to answer it ahead of time what
we've what we've done in order to reach
that number for that one part of of uh
setback and sighting is we've reviewed
uh what many of the states in the region
have in their existing rules and what we
found that is 500 feet is actually more
protective than the regulatory practices
in the Northeast and we can share those
numbers with you for what other um what
other states have have uh after we
finish if you'd
like so again what this rule would say
now is the footprint of a landfill shall
not be located within 500 ft of any
perennial surface water body measured
from the closest Bank of a stream and
closest shore of a lake as applicable so
that's moving from 200 feet to 500
feet also in that section is 80403
G what we're looking to do is revise the
100-year flood Hazard Zone to to the
500-year flood plane to ensure
protection against severe floods across
time what we also found is that we
currently don't have a definition of
Hazard Zone in our rules so let's use
flood plane which is actually a defined
term in the solid waste
regulations onto setback requirements
and that's an 80404 a we're proposing
increasing the setback of a landfill
footprint to a property line and
requiring a minimum vegetated buffer
this is going to ensure adequate space
in the setback for landfill operations
while also ensuring a vegetation buffer
to screen visuals and assist in
mitigating noise and litter from
traveling
offsite can you just pardon me is that
8045 a 80404 a 4
sure we're at we're proposing to add a
new requirement under 80404
C so right now there're already exist
the 500 foot uh vegetative buffer
between the footprint of a landfill in
residences what this would do is add the
same requirement for a vegetated buffer
between the landfill footprint and
Residential Care Facilities nursing
homes and prisons Beyond just residences
to provide a vegetated buffer between
the lyfi footprint and places where
people reside for an extended period of
time besides the
residents 80404 D we're looking to add a
requirement that landfills be set back
1,000 ft of which 500 ft nearest the
property line are vegetated between the
landfill and places where vulnerable
populations like dayc carees and
hospitals are regularly present on a
daily or a near- daily basis so that
reads there shall be a minimum of 1,000
foot setback of which the 500 feet
nearest the property line shall be
vegetated for properties containing
Public Schools licensed daycare
facilities and
hospitals
now I'd like to move on to section 805
within the chapter 800 and that's design
requirements pardon sure uh I just wanna
because we're going through a lot um did
you say that that also included schools
public schools
schol so design requirements they
outline requirements for the design of
landfill liners and liner systems leate
collection and removal systems storm
water man Management systems and the
design of landfill caps along with other
General design requirements within
805 so let's start with the Lee
collection removal system design
standards we're going to talk about
80506 we're looking to add requirements
for a backup high water alarm and alarms
to Auto dialers and that would alert
facility Personnel to the to the we're
looking to add those to the requirements
for pump stations located outside the
the landfill
footprint in 80506 P these are both
related we're adding a requirement that
automatic dialers which will alert
facility Personnel we're looking to add
the requirement that auto dialers to
tanks sumps and other lee8 storage units
uh with high water alarms so what we've
seen recently is an increase in lee8
releases and we believe that to be
partially due to in some in insufficient
or inoperable alarm and notification
systems Within um at the landfill um
most landfills are already equipped
these systems so what this is going to
do is promote consistent consistency
among all of the landfills and bring
these facilities in line with the normal
standards of
practice we've also not we've also added
Provisions regarding maintenance of
auxiliary or backup equipment in
806 in the storm water management system
design standards we wanted to bring to
your attention um the require
requirement for systems to be designed
for a 50-year storm event as opposed to
existing 25-year storm event this is
basically you know planning for the
potential um once a landfill cap is
constructed unless it fails the system
will not be upgraded to accommodate the
increasing number and frequency of
severe weather events that we've seen
increasing from the existing 25e storm
event to a 50-year storm event also
aligns with existing design standards
that are set by our alteration of
terrain program within their regulations
a the alteration of terrain program
doesn't use a 25e storm event in their
rules at all so 50 would put us in line
with um other existing regulations for
storm
events and then I believe the last item
in 05 we wanted to bring to your
attention is one specifically relating
to Municipal Solid Waste we call mssw
landfill design standards and that's
a we propose adding a requirement that
the bottommost liner of the landfill we
call that the secondary liner so in in a
landfill be a composite liner and then
within this rule we refer to another
citation which specifies what a
composite liner shall consist of for
your awareness landfill permites right
now are proactively using composite
Liners in portions or all of um of their
liner systems without the regulatory
requirement and in many states in the
area at least one composite liner is
required so the language would read
existing languages landfills receiving
Municipal Solid Waste shall be designed
as double lined facilities pursuant to
80505 new language and the bottommost
liner shall be a composite liner
pursuant to next Rule and the next rule
outlines what a composite liner shall
consist of which is a geom membrane
liner and a soil
component next under part 880 six the
operating requirements those outline the
specifics for operations of a landfill
such as waste placement uh when cover
material should be placed on an area of
a landfill where waste is actively being
placed management of leachate management
of decomposition gases as well as
inspections maintenance and monitoring
of an active
landfill under the inspections
maintenance monitoring and Reporting
requirements we are adding a section in
D6 so we're adding that liquid in the
primary leachate collection system also
be tested in July for a suite of
Wastewater parameters including pasas so
this is the leachate that is produced
from direct contact with the waste
within the primary liner system so the
water that filters directly through the
waste gets collected at that first
bottom that first uh liner touching the
waist and this is to ensure that that
should a wastewater treatment receiving
facility be unexpectedly able on should
be I apologize this is to ensure that
should a wastewater treatment receiving
facility be unexpectedly unable to take
the liquid that a commonly accepted
Suite of recently conducted analytical
characterization testing is available so
that the permit can seek can quickly
seek a new wastewater treatment
facility under our rules landfills are
required to have at least two receiving
facilities available but we acknowledge
that volumes storm events and other
disruptions may require quickly seeking
seeking another facility this is going
to ensure that facilities are prepared
to flex with the available Wastewater
disposal
capacity so we're adding an analytical
characteristics based on representative
samples taken from the primary leech a
collection system um and there's it's a
list of 10 which I believe are um are
commonly accepted it's called the 10
state
standard
so the the receiving facility would have
to be prepared to take any leate that
had these compounds so this is just to
ensure that there's complete
transparency between we're going to we'd
like to ship you our leate here's what
it contains to make sure that they're
able to to receive that
MH in
G3 we propose adding a requirement for
annual Odor Control reports to be
filed right now the way we regulate that
is is generally through um terms and
conditions of individual permits but
we're looking to standardize that
requirement so we're looking to um add
an odor an annual Odor Control report so
that all landfills are taking a critical
look at their operations and striving
towards continual Improvement and this
would also make our department aware of
efforts being undertaken and what
options might be available so creating a
standard of practice some do it some
don't want we'd like to standardize
that and then under the general
operating other operating standards
section
e we are adding a requirement that a
pery post to its publicly available
website a contact method or information
for the public to use to submit
questions and issues related to that
facility and this is generally to assist
in communication when there are issues
you know some issues like odors are
temporal and need to be responded to
quickly and only if the landfill is
notified timely by that um by the person
with the complaint um only if they're
notified can The Operators respond to to
an attempt to troubleshoot the
issue moving on to 807 part 807 which
are the closure requirements these
detail landfill closure and post closure
requirements including post closure use
and uh post closure use is a brand new
section and that's what we wanted to
bring your attention to this
morning just to set this up previous to
this proposed language for post um for
post closure use any permit could um um
seek approval for any activity at the
landfill and our department really had
no guard rails on or minimum standards
on what we could approve or not approve
there was actually just one sentence in
the rules and we've struck that that
sentence existed in
80750 and that language said the permit
shall obtain Department approval via the
permit modification procedures provided
in the rule for any post closure
activity at the site not specifically
approved by the facility permit so it
really left things very general and what
we're trying to do by adding the new
section
80706 is to uh detail Provisions for
when approval of a PO post closure use
is required we'd like to require some
minimum standards on the post-closure
use how to seek post closure use
approval post closure use construction
requirements and what occurs when a post
closure use
ends this is going to assist in
encouraging reuse of land while also
remaining protective of the
environment
sure absolutely yes uh one of the items
that when we first proposed this idea I
believe it was it must have been in the
July public input session I think the
the the term we were we were looking at
at the time was to prohibit permanent
structures on top of a landfill and what
we heard very loud and clear was but
wait solar arrays could be considered a
permanent so we revised the language and
what you what we see before you um we
change from permanent structure to uh
prohibiting residential and commercial
buildings on top of a
landfill how do you feel we're
okay that's a lot of work uh
representive Davis
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question my my questions uh
I'm curious about a setback the setback
from bodies of water has been changed
from 200 feet to 500 feet sure and I'm
not sure why that number we had heard a
lot of testimony about uh leachate time
through through distance and I thought
that was on the right track to make each
site specific instead of just an
arbitrary number I'm I'm just curious
about that
so no why don't you
okay okay thank you for your question um
of course the setback is just one of
many criteria that the landfill need to
meet and uh maybe um a very important
criteria to look at at the same time as
the 500 foot setback from surface water
is the new requirement
that um any spills be able to be
remediated from groundwater before
they before they get off of the property
um we focus on protecting the
groundwater at landfills and if we
protect the groundwater and um then we
find that we don't see impacts to
surface water New Hampshire's landfills
uh don't show a history of impacting
surface water even with our existing
rules so taking that in context um when
we establish a number like 500 foot set
back to surface water in our rules we
look at many factors in order to come up
with the number um it includes what is
protective of the environment and human
health what is practicable what
other New Hampshire rules establish as
similar protective standards and what
other states establish as protective
standards so as leam mentioned the 500
foot is um the median minimum setback of
other states in our region so it's what
has been um accepted as protective or
even more protective than what many
states have in the area uh and also um
if you look at
the floor that we're suggesting for the
formation permeability beneath the
landfill you look at the typical
groundwater gradient
um typical paracity what you find is
that 500 feet gives you about three
years of travel time to the surface
water body so this is what we're
proposing in this draft proposal uh as
the 500 foot
setback thank
you yeah I have lots of thoughts um so I
don't know if we are you finished
presenting in total okay so I didn't
want to R um
I thank you um thank you madam chair um
so one of the other things that I was
thinking about was uh going back to the
auto dialers and the alarms in I think
it was
um is there a list of entities that
should be I'm assuming this is an auto
dialer
to municipalities or or the facil like
where is that that auto dialer alarm
going so it it would
be we normally deal with folks that have
scada so this would be this would be
alerting
facilities real time of any sort of of
of issue so it would go it would go to
the facility operator owner of that
facility does it also then go anywhere
else potentially to a municipality or
any other entity that might have some
Juris ition over the
issue we could take a look at being a
little more prescriptive of that at this
point it's it's not that it's not that
prescriptive in the in the proposed rule
okay and I would just add that elsewhere
in the rule um there are requirements
established for when there is an event
at a facility they need to contact this
list of entities which would include um
local authorities and the state so that
might they may not be uh notified real
time but the operators have the
requirement to to follow follow
up yeah for a followup no I think do wna
I'm good with you're good you said you
had a bowon yeah I do have a bon of
question I was measuring bowon as one no
um my other question then I guess was
about the geoc composite liner so Geo
obviously means Earth or Earth and like
so um is there a limitation on what type
of organic materials can be used or is
that well
defined give me a minute to check to see
what our current rules
say we have a section
80504 that uh specifies composite liners
just want to make sure that I'm giving
you the full context
here
so um what I mentioned during my Fast
and Furious was uh 880504 C where
composite liner shall consist of a
geomembrane liner and a so component but
what I failed to mention is 80504 B goes
a little bit more in depthness existing
rule 80504 B uh specifies that
geomembrane liners shall meet or exceed
the following specifications so the
liner material shall have a minimum
thickness of 60 mil liner material shall
be chemically compatible with
anticipated waste and late
characteristics and seeming methods with
which involve the use of solvents shall
incorporate quality assurance quality
control procedures to assure protection
of groundwater and surface water
resources and then again uh C composite
liner shall consist of a soil component
as specified by a which is a geomembrane
liner or a manufactured geosynthetic
clay liner which is abbreviated by GCL
and that would have to have a hydraulic
conductivity of not less than 5 * 109
cmers per
second and if I can please I think if I
remember correctly we were considering
language before ours which would have
been to the negative fifth power so how
did you I um when we were talking about
other types of legislation before us so
um I'm just curious of the change or the
scope I mean I think we also talked
about it relative to distance to travel
um so I
guess where did that come
from
uh yes so um 5 time 10 to the9th would
be more protective than 10 to theg 5th
and we can talk with our Engineers about
that and get back to you about that um
because I don't I don't have that
information here right now today
okay do you have a
question
so right now the public comment is for
from when it came out the draft was 20
days could be 2021 yep 20 days so and
after that point then there's then it's
all of this whole discussion with the
public is cut off no that what we've
done so far is uh three informal
sessions um two public input listening
sessions and then an actual Deliverance
of a draft which is what we' sent last
week we don't enter formal rul making
until we we file an initial proposal and
we anticipate doing that
in January to February then we start the
actual real formal rulemaking process
and baked into that is a formal public
hearing which will don't hold into this
but will'll probably hold sometime
around February and that in and of
itself comes with a public input and a
formal public comment period as well
okay
so would it be helpful um within this
draft to take so much of the legislation
it you know I have not I've only gone
through about five pages of this I you
know focused on a lot of the Bold
factors that you have in there but
there's a ton of stuff missing and um
especially about Hydro geological
conditions and um places where a
landfill just won't happen and uh and
that's some stuff that's that's truly
missing also there's nothing that's
talked about in that closure area um in
regards with
landfills that
um so for
example a landfill is closed in what
period of time before and what distance
were another landfill like if they put
in a permit so for example you have a
landfill that's been closed and no one
else could propose another landfill in
the area for whatever said said date
time distance that really should be in
there because you know um that's quite
protective as well so you have a
landfill that's shut down um that's
being monitored um you know and somebody
wants to literally propose a landfill
three or four miles down the road from
one that just closed um so that's an
incessant burden on an uh on a location
so I just don't understand why there's
none of these specifics that are in
there so would that be helpful that you
guys get a whole kind of laundry list of
some of the things that we feel like are
missing site specific stuff and all of
that we would welcome um from from the
committee your
your a briefing on your thoughts similar
to those yes okay thank you that that's
the exact reason why we that's the exact
reason why ahead of formal will making
we've tried to take another step um to
give everyone Ample Ample opportunity to
provide
comment to to that regard would it be
helpful for the subcommittee to provide
some specific questions and then at the
next session you guys could provide
feedback to those questions is that it's
always going to be helpful from our
standpoint to be able to help us help
you help us help okay and represent
Penza if you could take the lead on that
in providing them a I
know that's so I figured I wasn't too
worried about that question is that okay
is that Mr chair if I can ask is that a
is that something we can all contribute
to yeah okay absolutely and then we can
sort of uh have a deadline for when we'd
like to have those back to the es for
our next meeting yeah I guess I would I
would think if it if it works with
everyone uh two weeks to get whatever
questions we've got to representative
Penza then um schedule a a next session
to review that and any other updates
for uh first week in December maybe does
that does that make
sense is there anyone else um that has I
comments I have another question yeah
absolutely please um before we yeah
sorry um one of the other questions that
I sort of had or I'm just thinking sort
of about here is around your Odor
Control report and I'm if I'm looking at
the notes correctly um this might be
something new or more enumerated than it
has been in the past so one of the
things that I was curious about was
whether or not within that older control
report you you talk about
uh categorizing or cataloging the data
around what actual odors there might be
or other types of concerns there might
be but are you also listing the the
products or items used to control those
odors so that individuals who may um
have questions later as enumerated in
8069 E might have access to that like or
those
other Odor Control methods rather like I
know sometimes there are odorizers and
other types of things
used thank you for the question I'm not
quite sure that I that I follow it it
I'm going to sloppily attempt to answer
I'm sure it's not the answer that you're
looking for um I think the only thing I
glommed on to was whether or not was
publicly available all of these reports
would be provided would be on our
website and viewable by the public I
know that wasn't your question but I
took the opportunity to answer it anyway
um yeah let me try and rephrase it I
guess the the methods that are used to
control the odors if there are chemicals
applied what are they if there are
things used um to what degree do those
like a material is sort of report within
that Odor Control report so let me take
that back to our Engineers I think we're
we were still on this the fledgling idea
of creating this report and some of you
might have have sat on some other recent
committees where we've um talked about
incorporating forms into Rule and so
what what we would expect to do is
create a form that would be required to
be filled out and we would add items
just like that if you're going to if
you're going to add an O an odorizer
what what does that contain we could
absolutely look at that making that
require
requirement thank you that's more of
where I was going thank
you okay ladies uh no further questions
on from the
subcommittee okay thank you so much for
your hard work and uh and we look
forward to working with you over the
next several months and we'll uh
schedule the next meeting sometime in
December early December thank you I
notice uh a lot of folks here interested
in this topic is there anyone else that
has input that's uh gerain to or review
of the de Ru making
process anyone else Madam
chair thank you Mr
chair
uh thank you very much for uh coming and
uh giving your report this morning uh
very IM informative uh and one of the
questions though that I would direct to
you is I'm interested to know for the
rules in
total um Are there specific rules
within your list of rules there that are
statuto required
um are what I mean by that
is are there rules there that were
specifically mandated to you
Dees um to have been included in your
rules and I'd be interested to know
which ones of those they
are um and I'd also be interested to
know the rule rules that you are now
making changes
to um to what extent have have they been
impacted by any kind of um new
technological information that you've uh
acquired I know you mentioned before
that like with the change to the 200t
setback that you've changed it to 500
ft that you did that as a median um with
respect to what other states surrounding
us or other I don't know which
particular States um have have had
different setback um
numbers I just I don't I I I I wouldn't
think or I hope that none of
these numerical changes that are being
made are done arbitrarily but that there
is some technological iCal reason why
those changes are being made and I I'd
like to have a little bit more
clarification on um on that particular
aspect of those numerical
changes and I hope I didn't take that
over but um those were some questions
that came to mind that I believe the
subcommittee would be interested in uh
in
knowing thank you madam chair
sure
and representative Murray please thank
you and and it is for the department so
I apologize for I just wanted to make
sure that I was clear on your website
you do have a whole administrative rules
sort of generator that has the ability
to pull things up by category one of
them is solid waste um and in there
there are sections that uh enumerate um
rules is adopted slash or certified and
then proposed so my question to you you
is um what are the Nuance differences
between adopted and certified and can
you give us a working definition so that
we can move like forward using that same
definition I can give you a working
definition thanks adopted means that
they have gone through the entire formal
rle making process certified is they are
certified by OS so we receive the final
um camera ready version which is called
the certified Rule and we receive that
from OS and that just depends on um
sometimes we get them fairly quickly it
just depends on 's workload um sometimes
it may take six months until the
department receives a a true certified
copy but for uh for all intensive
purposes the adopted rule is the is is
the rule it's the rule that we follow um
usually the certified rule they might
you know they might find an errant comma
um it's never anything that's that's
substantive thank you very much and why
while you're there uh any response to
representative Aaron's question or do
you want to get
into the details of that at the next
session I think it would behoove
everyone if we had the opportunity to
come back and we could really fully
flush out those those questions they're
very very uh very good questions okay
and and and and a followup to that is
and representative Davis
mentioned uh clarification
on site specific requirements especially
analysis of the movement of groundwater
and the rate of movement and how and how
that pertains to the rul making
process and I'm sure that representative
Penza will have that question in her
form
too noted thank you thank you ma'am
anything else any other aliis
representative
Davis
Penza one question yes ma'am
okay so there's been um and I'm sure you
guys have heard it there's been a a lot
of um constituents I'm in Rochester we
have TurnKey landfill there there's a
huge odor problem that has been taking
place of course because of the amount of
rain and um and constituents are feeling
as if their voices aren't heard so some
of these rule changes will help with
that I assume um but where is the
monitoring aspect of what's going on um
is that a piece I mean I saw some of
that in bold that are some changes in um
the rules but it seems as if um the
complaints are kind of falling on deaf
ears and um of course I'm only one
person in Rochester to hear them
so let me make a deal with you why don't
when when next time we come we can be
prepared to sort of outline the from
Soup To Nuts in every part of our rules
how complaints are uh investigated how
we receive them and how uh sort of our
our process to walk through that if that
would be helpful because there's there's
different parts and different rules that
deal with um odor complaints or
different nuisance complaints and
they're not just in the landfill
sighting rules we have overall rules
overarching rules in the 1,00 and 1100s
that speak a bit to that so I'll make a
note of that and we can come prepared to
discuss that topic in
totality any
albas all right okay uh if there are no
further questions then uh I will
schedule a meeting for first week in
December and uh we'll get back and get
into some more details and see how the
progress is going again thank you so
much for your hard work and for uh
coming under the rapid gunfire here
today and uh look forward to seeing
everyone in December meetings journ
thank
you
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
environment
agriculture I'd like to start uh our uh
our session this afternoon off with uh
Pledge of Allegiance led by
representative
Katon to the flag of the United States
of America and to the Republic for which
it stands one nation under God
indivisible liberty and justice for all
thank
you just one announcement I'd like to
make before we get underway with our
exec session this afternoon and that is
um uh we were told this morning in our
chairs and vice chairs meeting that uh
for for folks who are uh having drink or
coffee or anything any food or whatever
please make sure you clean up and uh
dispose of your bottles and cans and
whatever in the trash prior to leaving
the room and let's not let's help our uh
maintenance staff so of one person I
understand uh to keep keep our building
clean so thank you for
that all right uh I will open up the
exec session on HB 37 which is uh EST uh
establishing a committee to study best
practices for companion animal
groomers and I would like to uh put
forth a motion of
itl on that
bill and do I hear a second on that
representative Morse thank
you and I will speak to that motion of
itl uh establishing a committee to stud
best practices for companion animal
groomers uh the committee is feeling
that we don't need this study as I we
have um put together a a consumer guide
to animal groomers which we will at some
point put uh uh up on the State website
somewhere either on the Department of
Agriculture website or uh the consumer
New Hampshire consumer safety
uh website or um there's also a Humane
treatment of animals website so uh there
was a feeling that this particular
committee to study uh was not necessary
do we have any uh questions or comments
about that
motion seeing none I would like the the
uh clerk to call the role on itl for
this bill representative
kraton I representative ktoa yes
representative verville I representative
Davis yes represent bruad I represent
kulan represent
Kenny represent Penza yes represent
smart represent Bixby yes represent s is
not here represent Duty yes represent
Murray yes represent Jama yes
representative H Haskins I
representative Howard yes representative
NAB I represent Morse yes represent Voit
yes Madam chair
yes 190 it passes do we want to put it
on
consent I'm fine with putting it on
consent any
objections on consent thank you very
much let me close the exec on HB
37 and open the exec on HB 122 relative
to
microenterprise home kitchen operations
and do I hear a
motion representative ktoa thank you
madam chair I'd like to make a motion to
itl do I hear a second Madam chair I
second the motion thank you
representative
NAB representative comto would would you
like to speak to your motion thank you
madam chair um last week I brought forth
an amendment um it was later deemed non
derain um the bill as written uh is not
ready for prime time the amendment would
have fixed that problem but it needs a
public hearing so at this moment itl is
the only way to
go thank you do we have any other
further discussion on this
bill seeing none I would direct the
clerk to call the role representative
kraton representative coma yes
representative verville I representative
Davis representative Brad I represent
kulan representative Kenny
representative Penza yes representative
smart yes represent Bixby yes
representative Duty yes representative
Murray yes representative Jama yes
representative H Haskins I
representative Howard
yes represent NAB I represent moris yes
represent Voit yes Madam chair yes 190
should we put it on the consent I'm fine
with putting it on consent
anybody else no thank you on
consent I will close out
HB
122 and move to open HB 326 prohibiting
the use of second generation an coagul
for denti sites do I hear a
motion yes um representative Bixby I
move uh itl on HB 326 FN do I hear a
second a second representative kraton
seconds would you like to speak to your
motion representative Bixby yes so um we
got a uh report from the uh Board of
pides control subcommittee that was uh
doing that was studying this and they
that report indicated that the federal
government was likely go to be uh
putting forward final rules uh in the
near future to cover this to to deal
with this issue and uh they had a um
essentially a summary of those rules and
what the feds were proposing is more
thorough than anything we could come up
with for a bill and more more targeted
uh so
uh it makes sense to let the federal
government bring that forward it should
be uh latest word is those should be
coming out in uh December or January uh
if there uh the federal government does
not come up with something uh by the end
of the of the spring we can go to the F
to our pde control board and request
that they do something at the state
level they have that Authority without
our leg legislation uh and we can uh
work with it at that point but I'm
hoping that the feds will have uh put
forward their regulations by then and we
won't and and that will help cover the
whole country with it so um we don't
need to do it at
this okay thank you any other
discussion seeing none I direct the
clerk to call the role on this vote for
itl thank you madam chair representative
kraton I representative ktoa yes
representative verville I representative
Davis yes represent Brad I
representative kulan represent Penny
represent
Penza yes represent smart represent
Bixby yes represent Duty yes represent
Murray yes represent Jam yes represent H
Haskins I represent Howard yes represent
NAB I represent moris yes repres Voit
yes Madam chair yes n 190 shall It Go on
consent I think it should go on consent
any other objections to that all right
thank you very much let me close out HB
326 and open up uh exec for HB
369 establishing a task force to provide
energy relief on farms do I hear a
motion yes I would like to uh I I'd like
to move to adopt Amendment
uh uh 2023 d235
5H uh to HB
369 do I hear a second I'll second
that representative Murray seconds uh
representative Bixby would you like to
speak to your motion yes so um the in
our discussion last week about this uh
Bill there were uh a couple of questions
raised uh one was whether uh the
appropriation that is uh in the
bill uh which uh is for fiscal year uh
2025 uh would uh whether the fact that
that is just a one-year appropriation uh
whether that would create a problem in
terms of whether the whether this
program would continue on and I talked
with OLS and they said unless there is
language in the bill that specifically
says that uh it will end after that
appropriation then it's the Department's
responsibility to continue the program
going by uh making appro making any
necessary Appropriations in the
following Year's budget uh so uh that
and he said that the bill as drafted was
or the amendment as
drafted uh drafted was entirely
appropriate for that um the second thing
that came up in our discussions last
week
was the uh the question of what counts
as a farm and uh what I had used on used
in the uh amendment that I was uh that I
brought in last week was uh a reference
to uh schedule F on on uh for federal
taxes and it was noted by uh both Rob
Johnson from the Farm Bureau and by uh
Mr Wilmer uh from the uh from C
extension that uh that could
inadvertently exclude some people and uh
Mr Wilmer from the from extension gave
me some language that extension uses
for uh their Farm mental health program
that uh they have found is very good in
terms of uh determining whether a farm
is a farm in the business for it as
opposed to a hobby Farm uh and uh so I
uh amended this amendment uses the
language that I got from uh Mr Wilmer uh
H with uh uh some minor adjustments in
order to make the the the grammar
workout correctly for a bill but um
that's uh that the language on what
counts as a farm is essentially drawn
from uh that existing program under
Co-op extension uh the
the amendment as a whole uh basically
takes what was uh initially proposed as
a as a task force which would have
gotten uh a number of highlevel people
into a room to talk about how we could
have uh better support for energy
infrastructure on farms into a program
to actually do that uh and uh what this
does is it uh creates a program within
the department of
agriculture uh that uh says that uh
there should
be an education program available for
Farmers that focuses on Farm Energy
Systems and farm uh engineering
infrastructure engineering and uh
provides advising for that so is housed
in the Department of Agriculture the
department of a agriculture will
contract with Cooperative Extension
using a memorandum of understanding
to get this work done uh and it is uh
and it would be one one extension field
specialist who would be performing that
work uh and this is an exact this is
basically um the same model that the uh
division of lands and forests uses for
County
Foresters uh the uh requirement for the
county Forest uh education is uh for for
for Forest foresting education is set in
uh lands and uh division of lands and
Forest statutes and it says that the
division will use a memorandum of of
understanding with extension to have
that uh forestry work done and uh so
it's basically uh the department
Contracting with extension uh so if
anybody has any questions about how that
works uh we have to answer
them okay representative
ktoa thank you madam chair and thank you
representative viby uh for for the
amendment um I do have concerns about
the criteria for a farm and I think it
excludes a huge population of beginning
Farmers or people that are trying to
farm in a crop isn't ready for 3 to four
years such as a a Vineyard um because
because uh the the three criterias here
do not include those Farms because one
uh it's not contributing to their living
costs at the
moment it's may be their principal
occupation but they're not
deriving any income from it and usually
they have a secondary source of income
until it's up and running and until
that's up and running they're not going
to you know they're they're they
supplementing uh their income and I
think that we're doing a disservice to
the other farmers in New Hampshire by
excluding
them anyone else representative Murray
thank you madam chair um thank you uh
representative Kat for your thoughts um
I also think that addition anytime we
can provide additional resources for
Farms um related to energy relief given
all of the instances in which we are
seeing sort of changes in our
environment are vitally important to the
availability of supporting and
diversifying our food and farming
initiatives so for that reason um I am
in support of HB uh 369 uh and the
amendment that we are is before US
Representative
Duty uh yes thank you madam chair um I
hear what representative quam coma is
saying however I really feel that this
is a first good step that is going going
to uh assist a number of the established
farms in New Hampshire um so I would
hope that we would uh pass this
amendment and this legislation and if in
the future we feel that there should be
some
modifications um I think we can do that
but in the meantime I think a lot of
farms are going to uh find a benefit
from a program that can get up and
running pretty
quickly representative ger
thank you madam chair this is a a
question for representative Bixby the um
the
amendment defines
Farm as says Farm means a farming
operation as defined in RSA
234a and as I look at
234a it would seem to include the
Enterprises that representative ktoa is
referring to the word Farm means any
land buildings or structures on which or
in which Agriculture and farming
operations or activity are carried out
or
conducted um so doesn't
234a which is cited in the amendment
cover uh the and and I agree with
representative compto that they should
be covered but my question is does does
that
RSA cover those Enterprises that are
representative comp was asking about Mr
representative Bixby that was directed
to you yes um so
the uh I think that representative coma
does have a point in that there there
might be some Farms that are excluded
however I'd like to also point out that
uh we are the first body that is
considering this piece of legislation
and uh I don't in general like saying
let the Senate fix it however one of the
things that um that that I am I I think
might be helpful is that uh the former
chair of this committee is on the Senate
body that will be hearing this and uh he
is uh maybe better versed in I probably
should have consulted with him about
this language before I got a prob went
through it but uh he is better versed in
what should be here than um than perhaps
I am and if it requires amending at the
Senate uh when it gets to the Senate I'm
sure that will happen happen uh and uh I
think that in the in order to get this
uh this program up and running faster it
makes more sense to pass it now than to
wait another couple of years until it
has
a uh it makes more uh in order to get
the language perfect so uh the language
may not be perfect now but in order to
get this uh get this out there so that
farmers can start using it I think we
should pass it now representative
Howard thank you madam chair I think
that the um intent of this amendment of
creating this position that for Farmers
to reach out to for help would not
necessarily be one that someone who is
in the position that that representative
ktoa has mentioned I think that if you
are in the early stages of farming you
have a day job so you can Farm you know
on the side
and see if your farm survives you're not
ready to take on a a an array of um of
solar panels or
whatever representative verville thank
you madam chair um I I agree with the
the ranking member we shouldn't send
bills that are flawed off to the senate
in hopes that they they they correct it
so I I agree with them 100% there my my
challenge with this bill is that it
grows the size of government it spends
money
that we know is tight for and I and I
see the faces but hear me out for
duplicative efforts there are so many
groups and
organizations that are Consulting and
providing assistance both both Technical
and financial for alternative energy um
schemes for for this that and the other
thing and I don't know any of them that
discriminates against Farms that would
be say just for an office building or or
for for maybe a strip mall or whatever
the business may be but yet this bill
we're going to Target to to just Farmers
so for me because it's duplicated
because there are already so many
programs like this I I I don't feel that
this is a good use of taxpayer money and
for that reason I'm a no thank you madam
chair okay anyone else representative
Bixby yes so
um we had we heard from Mr Wilmer from
cooperative extension last uh last week
that uh one of the advantages in having
Cooperative Extension do this sort of
work is that they are they don't have a
uh they don't have money involved in it
so if you go to a uh an to a uh solar
panel firm and say I want you know I
want to some advice on how to um improve
my energy infrastructure on the farm
they may direct you just towards solar
panels and what uh and I I don't
remember the exact uh example that Mr
Wilmer gave but he gave an example of
one farm that he had worked with where
he they had gotten advice from a someone
a professional in the field and that
advice actually didn't make sense
because it didn't take into into account
the enti the whole uh the holistic
function of the farm so maybe maybe what
the farm needs isn't solar panels maybe
it is something that will uh you know a
battery bank that will create buffering
against uh demand charges and that the
solar panels wouldn't make the most
sense at that point or maybe it is uh
installing you know um a uh Reverse
Osmosis System something that the that
the solar panel firm wouldn't
necessarily know about uh what this
position is is someone who will know
enough about Farm Technology including
appropriate energy technology to help
advise the farm specifically on their
needs for making a holistic program uh
uh technical upgrade to the farm as
opposed to the peac meal advice that you
might get from another source so uh this
is not dup duplicative it is in fact
something that is very appropriately
targeted for our farming
Community thank you representative ger
thank you madam chair yeah I I wanted to
uh also uh representative Bixby beat me
to the punch a little bit but with due
respect my colleague at the end of the
table here uh representative verville
say this isn't duplicative what the
testimony that we heard was that it
actually would allow the agency to
expand the kinds of services they
already provide the testimony made it
clear that this was really valuable uh
uh information help that our Farmers
need we're doing it now this would allow
us to
expand those services and uh and extend
the benefit to more Farmers so it's not
duplicative it expands on something that
we're already
doing representative
Howard in fact um in question in the
question and answer with that with Mr
Winer he I asked him if it was a
necessary redundancy and an expansion of
expertise and he said that um that there
would be an expectation that they would
be helping with things that are already
in existence but there would be an
expansion of expertise and I'm pretty
sure that the um services are offered
without charge from the extension
represent
verval so to paraphrase what I heard
these things are already being offered
we're just trying to expand the program
if the extension wants to expand the
program then I would say uh in another
year when we be begin the state
budgeting process they should put in for
an exp expanded program um at that time
and not do this um outside of the
outside of the budgeting process this is
this is expanding stuff that we're
already doing they could do that they
could certainly do that um without us so
um with that I would say I would say no
this is this is not uh not a bill I can
support thank you madam chair anyone
else representative ger
yeah thank you mam I would just add that
we talked about that already uh and uh
some folks on the committee brought up
the fact that different counties may be
willing to contribute more to the
extension to try to expand these
services but as we talked about that is
a separate kind of process it involves
decisions that are made at the county
level that we can't know or or depend on
so the the question about how uh through
um uh the uh extension services this
could be done as you said we we had that
discussion and the um the official who
spoke with us at our last hearing made
it clear that this was a way to provide
those Services now and that in the
future there is the possibility for
expansion on on the uh on the part of
extension but uh that this committee can
do something now without waiting for
that to happen so I just want to
reiterate that was part of the
discussion uh I would remind our our
committee that we had about this bill
last
time representative Ville thank you
madam chair so what I would what I would
say is if the bill was more expansive
and not so targeted so that the the
group that's reaping benefit from this I
mean if this is really that that needed
it can't be just that needed on farms
there have to be other businesses there
have to be uh other other aspects of our
communities that could benefit from such
consultation from from state government
and when we narrowly focus it down into
farms for me it becomes less palatable
if it was a more Universal program Open
to more people I would be more receptive
to it but at this point um it it's too
tightly narrow representative
kraton thank you madam chair just to be
clear we're voting the the motion on the
table is OTP on the amendment yes on the
amendment okay so we're everyone's
talking about the bill um so if we vote
on the
amendment and it passes then we'll go to
otpa yes sir and that and that's based
on the amendment if we vote on the
amendment and it fails then the next
minut the next vote is on the initial
bill right with without the amendment
correct okay so I just wanted to make
sure that that was what we're voting on
okay represent Murray uh thank you madam
chair regarding the amendment and to to
your point uh representative I just want
to make sure that
um I understand what you are uh talking
about in in your desire to expand the PO
potential pool or applicant pool of
types of entities that might uh use such
a service I think we talked about that
at length during our last Committee
hearing and um we really uh at least
from what I was understanding in the in
the general Vibe of our conversation was
that we we felt like Farms really do
need to have an additional Avenue and a
a sort of a um a source to in addition
to programs like reap have other
resources available to them to be able
to um look at other alternative um
energy options so I just wanted to make
sure that we're clear there thank you I
think in the interest of time I'd want
to um uh call a vote have the clerk call
the role on this amendment and uh
proceed with
that Madam chair the motion is to adopt
the
amendment representative kraton I
representative coma no representative
verville nay represent
Davis represent Brad no represent
kulan represent Kenny represent Penza no
represent
smart represent Bixby yes represent Duty
yes represent Murray yes on the
amendment represent Jama yes represent H
Haskins I represent Howard yes represent
NAB yes represent moris yes represent
Voit yes madam chair
yes 11 to8 the amendment is
adopted okay do I hear um motion for
otpa on HB
369 I move otpa on uh Amendment uh on as
amended with Amendment uh 2335 h on HB
369 do I hear a second I'll second that
thank you representative Murray would
you like to speak to your motion
representative Bixby I think we have
discussed it and uh so uh I think let's
just go straight to a vote
okay uh I would call for U discussion on
this but I think we have discussed it so
um because the amendment does replace
the bill so uh
um uh I called I asked the clerk to call
the role on that otpa thank you madam
chair uh representative kraton nay
represent ktoa no representative Ville
nay representative Davis no represent
Brad no represent kulan represent Kenny
represent Penza no represent smart no
represent
Bixby yes represent Duty yes represent
Murray yes represent repr Jam yes
represent H Haskins I represent Howard
yes represent NAB I represent moris yes
represent Voit yes madame chair
yes 10 to nine motion
passes
okay I close the uh exec on HB
369 and I open the exec on HB
493 eliminating the state meet
inspection program do I hear
um oh I'm sorry on that uh so for HB
369 um the um representative Bixby will
be writing the majority
report and who would be be who would
like to write The Minority Report on
that representative veral go for
it
okay um HB 493 uh eliminating the Meat
Inspection program um do I hear a motion
on that yes I representative Bixby um I
move itl do I hear a second Madam chair
I didn't I'd like to second that
representative ktoa seconds uh
representative Bixby would you like to
speak to your motion yes so um I brought
this um bill in as a request of the
department and uh there is also uh at
the same um a Senate bill this term that
uh is looking at uh the um question of
availability of solder facilities and on
non or both amenable and non amenable
animals and it seemed like it was uh
inappropriate to uh decide to get rid of
these statutes before we had had that
study committee looking at this
issue okay any discussion on
this seeing none I'd like the clerk to
call the role thank you madam chair uh
representative kraton yay represent ktoa
yes represent verville yay represent
Davis yes represent bruad yes represent
kulan represent Kenny represent
Penza yes represent smart represent
Bixby yes represent Duty represent
Murray yes represent Jama yes represent
H Haskins I represent Howard yes
represent NAB I represent moris yes
represent Voit yes Madam chair yes
190 on consent um I would like to put it
on consent with without
objection okay thank you and I will
close out the uh exec on HB
493 and open the exact on HB 602
relative to landfill sighting do I hear
um a
motion represent Penza yes I'd like to
make a motion to amend with uh
223-233 3H on HB 602 do I hear a second
representative hasin seconds
representative penzo would you like to
speak to your motion
please so HB 602 is replaced with a in a
sense a preliminary application process
so most other states have a two-step
process some even a three-step process
for new landfill applications wherein
the developer only needs to submit a
preliminary application so by requiring
an initial application early
identification of unsuitable sites can
be identified and eliminated from
consideration without prejudice early
this helps avoid investing time and
resources in a site that will ultimately
be deemed unsuitable for a landfill
saving both the applicant and agency
valuable resources and if D Dees wishes
it can signal to the developer and the
public that by approving a preliminary
application the presumption is that the
entire application will likely be
approved with or without
modifications overall a two-step process
for new landfill applications helps
ensure a more robust and comprehensive
proposal evaluation leading to better
decision-making reduced environmental
and public health risks and increased
public trust in the landfill approval
process it is also intended to promote
sustainability and compliance with
environmental
regulations thank you for that do we
have any discussion on this
representative H Haskins thank you madam
chair I'd just like to say that we think
our Amendment clarifies some of the
language um we also think that it gives
Dees the kind of direction that we
believe they're looking for so we see
this as a positive step to both um
protect the environment and also allow
industry the chance to submit in a
two-step process their permit
application and get a ruling on that
before we go further thank you thank you
anyone else have any comments
representative Howard I have one
question um so uh representative Penza
you mentioned that it would that it the
presumption that it would pass is part
would be the result of of the passage of
the first part the the second part would
would be passed is that true or is that
in the bill I didn't see that no no no
no no so B basically it's for for the
industry so if an industry gets their
pre-application approved most likely
that is positive for them you know on
the advice of Dees of course that it was
probably going to move forward with or
without modifications so it's it's also
signaling to you know the applicant that
you know things look good on a
preliminary fashion but that's not in
the
bill anyone else represent ger thank you
madam chair just like to briefly
reiterate uh my point of in our last uh
meeting in support of the bill which is
that in numerous meetings with Dees what
they repeatedly ask us for is uh a
balance between Direction and
flexibility and and I think this does
exactly that so we're giving them
Direction in terms of having this
preliminary process but we are not
dictating any content we are not
dictating any criteria we're not telling
them how to do their jobs we're simply
setting up a preliminary stage that will
save both Dees and the companies who are
applying time and
money anyone else representative Bixby
yeah so um there's some question about
whether uh the current uh rules process
that Dees is already going through uh
whe whether this bill might create some
sort of a conflict with that and in fact
I think that this is actually a
complimentary Bill uh because uh for the
for the full permit process Dees needs
to put together those rules uh in any
case and once they have those rule the
rules for the full permit process uh
established they will know better what
would count as a uh very as a highly
problematic situation versus something
that could be uh corrected by uh a
permit U modific or an application
modification and they can use that
knowledge of what would be a a re you
know an unsurmountable problem in order
to come up with their list of what would
count as a prohibitive condition uh for
that for that pre- permit process and so
I think that this that uh this bill
actually works uh nicely in conjunction
with uh their current rules man rules
updating
process thank you representative
verville thank you madam chair so I I'm
I'm a no on this and the reason I'm a no
on this is I find it hard to believe
that a company that's going to try to
site a
landfill is not going to do their
homework early and often to try to dot
every i and cross every T before
proceeding forward it seems to me that a
corporation wouldn't take a a two-phase
approach where they took a they take a
very uh broad 40,000 foot view of it G
whiz you know this this looks like it'll
fit let's propose it and then we can dig
down into the details later as long as
they they green light it that's that's
not really that's not really how
business uh evaluates risk on investment
so I I find it hard to believe that any
company would propose sighting a
landfill somewhere where they honestly
believe that they did not stand a very
good chance of meeting all the
permitting require reement so that they
can get their their project uh approved
in fact one of the one of the biggest
fears of of any
investment is that you miss a
detail that comes in at the 11th hour
and and burns the house down right
because it it happens there are
unfortunate uh oversights when people
are assessing risk and making plans to
go forward there's always the unforeseen
and and sometimes those unforeseen
things uh cause the cause failure in the
in the project and so for for that
reason I I don't think that this bill is
necessary it's my opinion um that that
the state has a process for this um and
that this isn't required and with all
due respect for that reason I'm a no
thank you madam chair representative
Katon thank you madam chair and I I
would
just say that I think the intent of this
bill is to prevent that got you at the
last minute that says how do we miss
this that's I think that's the intent of
the bill is to prevent what you just
said it does m Madam chair I I certainly
agree with the representative that
that's the intent of the bill but I
don't believe that it's necessarily
going to deliver on on that hope and for
that reason I'm I'm I'm representative
ger thank you madam chair just like to
remind my colleagues on the committee
that as we discussed in our last session
this is not at all un common and quite
the opposite is quite common for States
actually to have a TW stage permitting
process for exactly these reasons and it
works so uh it is not as I said um it's
far from unheard of in the business and
businesses who work as they do here in
New Hampshire and other states are
entirely familiar with Stage permitting
processes representative H Haskins thank
you madam chair um yes building on what
my colleague uh representative jamana
just said this is is a short application
this initial permit application is a
short application just to get rid of any
disqualifying um criteria that would be
unsuitable for a landfill and that
indeed is what other states do as well
thank
you representative
rville but Madam chair if that was if
that was correct then why would a second
phase be required if the first if the
first phase is to ensure that that
everything checks out to proceed with a
project then why why do you need the
second phase well that's the way I
interpret your your remarks and and if I
misunderstood I apologize representative
H Haskins a short application is a short
application so of course it doesn't go
through all the criteria we are giving
Dees a lot of latitude here we're not
putting stringent requirements on them
we're just saying in this initial short
application the first permit application
are there disqualifying criteria that
they could go back to the um applicant
with and they'd still have time to
adjust if adjustment were feasible and
this is the kind of process that we
think our state deserves just like other
States Representative Murray uh thank
you madam chair um to um that point I
there are many circumstances in which
preliminary application phases um do
exist for other types of things and I
think the members uh representative hot
skins is exactly correct um sometimes an
entity will come back and say hey we
need you to address these things or
enumerate this a little bit more and um
in addition to just um so I think there
are two ways in which something like
this could be used for for remedying an
error or an oversight or then also where
there's a a a grave concern of some
other nature thank you okay any other
questions representative ktoa thank you
madam chair
so Dees is writing the rules right
now okay and if this was so important
this preliminary process why does it
only in effect until July 1st
2025 represent
poens so this isn't this isn't in effect
until July 1 2025 it's basically saying
that if Dees needs more time now we're
giving them to have the rules completed
until July 21 2025 right now the rules
are supposed to be done in July of 2024
that's the line on the back that's what
that's speaking to not about this
preliminary process can I speak on
something else
sure we all know that um in a perfect
world that
corporations industry um are always
working on the you know the best
interests of people but just in New
Hampshire alone and this isn't even
talking about landfill we all know what
happened with s gobain that is now like
poisoned an entire region of the state
we know that there's many times that
there's profits over people and so for
you know just on in representative
verville's you know just in responding
to that we can't be naive to that so
having a a preliminary and if someone's
going to try to you know push something
through that is right on the cusp of not
being a a real proper location for a
landfill then you know it's a good thing
it's just putting another layer in to
protect you know everybody that's
involved so I think that we can't be
naive to the fact that um not
everybody's always looking out for the
best interest of the citizens of New
Hampshire
thank
you representative verville yeah Madam
chair I apologize I I I I think I I
missed something of of rather weighty
importance so the effective date of the
bill is 2025 the rules are supposed to
be completed in 2024 so if this if this
bill passes and becomes law will that
potentially Kick the Can down the road
on the deadline for the new
rules
represent
Potenza it doesn't kick the can down the
road it's basically saying that if this
goes into effect and they they have more
time if they need them for the for the
rules that's it that's giving them more
time if Dees needs more time it extends
the deadline for them Madam shair
represent vervo so I I I appreciate the
answer but it it sounds to me like the
short answer is is yes that if this
becomes law instead of having to have
the new rules in place next year it
potentially adds another year for for
new rules and and that's for me that's
another reason to be a no thank you
madam chair representative Murray uh
thank you madam chair if I'm looking at
on the amendment on page two line two it
says or until the reopt rules are
effective so I think that there is the
opportunity for them to just continue
along as they are
now thank you than you all right you
know um in term again uh in the interest
of time uh I'm going to call ask the
clerk to call the role on the Amendments
adoption of the
Amendments thank you madam chair uh
representative kraton yay representative
coma no Representative vervo no
representative
Davis represent bruad no represent
kulan represent Kenny
represent
Penza yes represent smart represent
Bixby yes represent Duty yes represent
Murray yes represent Jam yes represent H
Haskins yay represent Howard yes
represent NAB yes represent Morris yes
represent Voit yes Madam chair
yes
13-6 the motion is
adopted the amendment is
adopted okay
um I'd like to hear a motion now for
otpa I'd like to make a motion to uh
adop
otpa for House Bill
602 do I hear a
second I'd like to second that
representative hasin seconds thank
you uh do we want to have any further uh
well no U representative Penza would you
like to um speak to your motion at all I
think we're good at this point we can
vote okay uh any other question or
comment before we call the rooll on this
otpa seeing none uh I direct the clerk
to call the role on otpa for HP 602
thank you madam chair uh representative
kraton yay Representative ktoa no
representative Ville no representative
Davis represent bruad no represent
kulan represent
Kenny represent
Penza yes represent smart no represent
Bixby yes represent Duty yes represent
Murray yes represent Jam yes
representative H Haskins I
representative Howard yes representative
NAB I represent moris yes represent Voit
yes Madam chair
yes 136 motion
passes okay um we will have I guess
representative Penza uh write the
minority uh the majority report on this
and who would like to write The Minority
Report on
this representative veral you will write
the majority the Minority
Report
okay I'm going to close out uh the exec
on HB
602 and I would like to have everybody
who's writing majority or minority
reports uh please make sure you get them
to me sometime
today uh ideally if you need till
tomorrow that's fine too but as soon as
you can I would like to have that you
can send it to me
electronically um our clerk also has the
uh committee
reports
um papers so that you can fill them
out this is to representative
Penza here you go and I want to thank
everybody for uh for their attention
their work on all of these
bills we had um a lot of good discussion
for the uh both the work sessions and
today and I appreciate very much all of
your input and your
Insight and I guess that does it for us
for this year Madam chair just a quick
question if I may sure representative H
Haskins um so in order to go on the
consent calendar does a bill have to be
um you have to have unanimous support
okay or I believe it's either one you
can have one person against but okay so
could be 182 also so if there if if uh
if there are one or two people voting
against it it can still go on consent if
those people who voted against it say
yes put it on consent I see thank
you madam chair yes am I also doing The
Minority Report on 369 because if so I
need that that form is welome yes sir
you are doing the minority reports on HB
369 and and HB 602 thank you madam chair
majority reports I got compto on 122
Aaron on on 37 Biby on 326 BBY on
369 BBY on
493 prend on
602 Peter you
got okay all right well we'll see you
all Thursday I guess during house
session and then uh all as I understand
these retain bills must be out by um the
17th of November we've completed the
work on
ours uh they will go to the house floor
sometime in
January and then after that um those
that pass the house will go on to the
senate for
consideration so that's how that's all
going to work thank you all very much
have a great rest of your day
and uh we'll see
you
that